okay let's go next to our caller from
the 703 area code who's calling from 703
today
hey David this is Frank McAvoy hey Frank
what's going on I actually live in
Washington DC now
oh all right well that is totally fine
that's allowed which is sort of swag
anyway the only thing is is that I since
I live in Washington I mean I can think
of a number of different things one
quotation is always good is from The
Tempest like how the hell must be empty
all the demons are here yeah and the
thing is it's really funny is that one
time I tried to joke with you and it
failed that's why I got turned up tend
not to joke with you too much but my
parish has a lot of Republicans
strolling in every now and then okay
like Ellie and Conway showed it two
years ago a month ago
Devon Nunez showed up well we took me
out my pastor Flitz about that I twist
about telling and Conway but I sort of
have a new routine and my stand-up
routine I talk about all Christianity
okay and and but anyway I was
interesting as well I noticed that you
interviewed Rick Wilson that's right
and I as he am in contact with him
through Twitter and email and stuff like
that at one time I asked him after I
read his book I said what do I have to
do to stay on your good side so that my
name doesn't appear in one of your
future essays right and what are you
saying
he laughed okay I guess that's a
reasonable reaction well particularly
when I read the thing in is everything
come touch just dies about Richard
Spencer in the future dying of
auto-erotic asphyxiation in the Nazi
uniform in the to sue right I basically
said I don't want to be in this anyway I
just want to conquer the head and called
in a while that's right I will work from
you Frank yeah I keep up the good work
man you know I'm doing well despite
being in the Trump administration you
know I guess I could apply to a job
there but I'd have to lie
my resume and have a lot of typos and
that would be the last job that ever
happened by one there you go well listen
Frank keep it up I would not advise you
to take a job in the Trump
administration and always good to hear
from you okay thanks a lot David okay
yep take care